tomorrow we got the gold medal game
so I need you to go back to your room
and get a good night's rest all right
sure thing coach will do it look at you
laying down the law
they respect me
[Applause]
welcome back you just saw a clip of the
brand new comedy Champions directed by
my dear friend Bobby Farrelly and a
little context what is the film about in
the in the movie Woody plays a
basketball coach a pro pro basketball
coach and he's a bit of a hot mess and
he gets in trouble and he gets court
ordered to coach a team of players with
intellectual disabilities so in order to
make the movie we had to find 10
actors who have intellectual
disabilities and they just all did a
great job in the movie and we have three
of them with us today
and I just proud to bring them out now
joining Bobby and I is some of that
amazing cast please welcome Madison
tevlin Kevin ayannucci and Joshua Felder
[Applause]
we're gonna have so much fun
hey Joshua how are you I'm happy to be
here oh my daughter and I spent last
night just falling in love with the
movie and you guys and Madison you had a
viral moment in 2015 where more than 8.3
million views were had like how did that
happen
so when my video went viral I didn't
know what to expect it was only really
meant for family and friends to see but
it got picked up to different news
stations and all that open up for a
special mix in LA and I still can't
believe I'm in this movie Champion with
Bobby and Woody
[Applause]
and you see with the Puma friends Joshua
and Kevin you both were like the best to
work with and I'm just so happy God will
work with you too
yeah
you're so good in the movie and by the
way Joshua you performed at the 2021
Super Bowl halftime show
um with the weekend
um that must have been very surreal oh
it was
I thought it was a dream my friends are
like okay this has got to be a dream
then finally the night of the Super Bowl
I realized it was reality when I when my
phones just started blowing up it was
going viral when I posted it especially
when I put down the caption being the
first person with a disability to ever
perform Municipal halftime show in
history which is
just so in this movie so much okay Kevin
is it true that you always wanted to be
an actor and like how did you feel when
you found out that you you know got this
part what was it like it is it's such
like a magical dream come true and being
in this movie was something that I've
never done and having a big pot in it
was the selling truly amazing so I can't
think enough to Bobby and also Woody as
well
you know each of you say that your
disability is sort of the least
interesting thing about you Madison may
I ask why you feel that way and I think
I could imagine but I can't wait to hear
it from you I always say this all the
time I have Down syndrome and it's at
least instant thing about me I know it's
a part of me but not all of me
and is there something else that we
should know about you Madison
then I have a really big heart and I
share basically everything with anyone
thank you Kevin what's the most
interesting thing I think the emergency
thing about me is generally everything
because I love being who I am more and
being here today is just I'm just
speechless in my mind so
laughs
speechless in your mind yeah
obviously that's the least interesting
thing about you what's the most
interesting thing about you
um well one thing I always say about my
high question autism I consider a
superpower because it helps me you know
break barriers and opens doors up for me
and I am proof of that because that's
how I got to be in this movie yes it is
and Joshua watch their amazing new film
champions in theaters on March 10th I
love you guys thank you so much for
coming here talking about this wonderful
movie
we'll be right back
[Music]